Speaker 1: . Hey, David, does it matter that most
trumpet's. Still don't accept that Donald Trump
lost. This is a really good question, there's two
answers. Does it matter electorally? No. I mean,
I know we hear about an audit looking for Bambu
Fiber's in Arizona and something's happening
in Michigan and North Carolina and, you know,
whatever, going to have zero electoral impact
other than continuing to push Republicans to try
to suppress even more of the vote in 2022 and
certainly in twenty, twenty four. For me, the
fact that most Republicans still don't believe
Trump lost is disturbing is because of what it
represents about the United States of America.
I don't believe that you can have long term
stability of institutions, of government,
of a society, of a culture when you don't even
have agreement as to what are facts. Again,
I didn't say what the facts are. There is not
even agreement now as to what constitutes a fact,
a statement of fact, an empirical
statement. And as I've said before,
we can disagree when it comes to our opinions
about things. But when one is presented with
facts about what took place and you respond with
my opinion is different. You were outside of the
world of empiricism. You were outside of the
world of fact and rationality and thinking.
How does a country remain stable when you
have so much of one party that believes
the person who won didn't really win? He
won by millions of votes other than some
typical anecdotal but statistically insignificant
irregularities. This was not a close election.
And then on the basis of that false belief, they
support a literal insurrection. The vaccines work
covid is real. Biden won. These are facts and they
don't believe them. They don't understand that
they are facts. It is not subject to opinion. And
so that the election is not accepted as legitimate
is really a sign of a mass radicalization.
It's a mass delusion. It's a tribal psychosis,
as I've referred to it before. But they believe
that even their ability to comment on this is
being silenced by their political enemies as they
see them. When it's not they're just wrong. They
just don't have the facts on their hands. And
if they start winning elections through more
voter suppression, which is what they plan to
do, and they ramp up this dehumanizing rhetoric
against their political enemies, history
points in bad directions when that happens.
So I worry we will see even more overt
political violence than we're already seeing.
We can look at all sorts of other injured
or imperfect democracies around the world
and you start seeing really ugly things happen in
and around elections. And so I think that there is
you know, it's easy to laugh off and say stupid
trampas who just can't accept the facts. Yeah,
that's true. But this is a much bigger issue.
And think back to when Trump was asked in 2016
if the results say you lost, will you accept that
you lost? Then he said, I'm going to wait and see.
I'll keep you in suspense. That was a dangerous,
vile statement that didn't get nearly the blowback
at the time. Everybody, even Republicans then
should have said that has to be rejected, period.
And Republicans voted the guy in. They did the
opposite, which in essence endorses that type of
thinking that leads and points towards tyranny.
So on a day to day level, listen, I don't want
an accountant who thinks Trump won. I don't want
a doctor who thinks Trump won. I don't work with
or hire people who have such delusional beliefs.
That's something I do at a personal level.
But there is a bigger issue here and the
degree of radicalization and separation
from reality that it points to. If we look
historically, it does not bode well for the
United States. That's where I would I would
leave it. And I'm curious to hear from you.
Make sure to get yourself a
membership on my website today
at Join Pakman Dotcom. And thus you will
get instant access to today's bonus of CNN.